OK. So a couple of physicists walk into a bar. Just kidding, they're not at the bar. They're at a school. Scientists in training.
好的。话说有几个物理学家走进了一家酒吧。开个玩笑，他们没去酒吧。他们在学校里。那是正在受训的科学家们。
I'm sure this story seems strange to you. But, to me, it was just-- you know, this is just like another day [LAUGHS] in the physics world.
我相信这个故事对你们来说很奇怪。但对我来说，这只是——你知道，这就像物理学界的日常[笑声]一样。
David Kestenbaum used to live in the physics world. These days, he lives in our world. He's a journalist-producer here at our show. But at the time of this story, he was getting a PhD in high energy particle physics at-- there's no way to avoid the name droppiness of what I'm about to say-- at Harvard University. But to paraphrase Us Magazine, Harvard physicists, in certain ways around the office, they're just like us.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）曾经生活在物理学界。如今，他生活在我们的世界里。他是我们节目的记者兼制片人。但在故事发生时，他正在攻读高能粒子物理学博士学位——我说出这些话时，完全无法掩饰那种想炫耀背景的感觉——就是在哈佛大学。不过套用《美国周刊》的话说，哈佛的物理学家们，在某些办公场合，他们其实也和我们一样。
There's always a time of day when someone made a pot of very strong coffee. And afterwards, everyone drank the coffee and then didn't quite want to work yet. And so we all stood around and talked about various things. You know, and there was a blackboard, or a whiteboard, or something there. And we were talking about how nobody really had girlfriends.
每天总有一段时间，会有人冲上一大壶浓咖啡。之后，每个人都喝了咖啡，然后还没完全进入工作状态。于是我们大家都站在一起，聊各种各样的事情。你知道，那里有一块黑板，或者白板，之类的东西。我们当时在谈论为什么没人有女朋友。
So, this being physics world, the next logical thing to do was to employ the power of mathematics to estimate the likelihood of finding a girlfriend. And so they start jotting down a calculation.
所以，作为物理学界，接下来的逻辑就是运用数学的力量来估算找到女朋友的概率。于是他们开始在板上草拟计算过程。
I guess it's sort of a variation on-- you know this thing called the Drake equation?
我想这算是某种变体——你知道德雷克方程（Drake equation）吗？
No.
不知道。
That is a way to estimate how many planets are out there that have intelligent life on them.
那是用来估算外星存在多少智慧生命的一种方法。
OK. So in this Drake equation, apparently you start with how many stars are in the universe. That is, all the places where there might be life, and then you subtract out all the stars that don't have planets around them, right? Because there can't be life there. And then you subtract out all the planets that are too far from the sun, or too close to the sun to support life, and so on, and so on. You get the idea. Until finally you come up with the likelihood of a planet with life evolved to the point of intelligence.
好的。在德雷克方程中，显然你要从宇宙中有多少颗恒星开始算起。也就是所有可能存在生命的地方，然后减去周围没有行星的恒星，对吧？因为那里不可能有生命。然后减去所有离太阳太远，或者离太阳太近而无法维持生命的行星，以此类推，等等。你明白这个意思吧。直到最后，你得出一个行星上演化出智慧生命的概率。
OK. They ran the same kind of math now except-- and I realize this is going to sound a little strange. But he say they replaced intelligent life with girlfriends.
好的。他们现在用了同样的数学方法，只是——我知道这听起来有点奇怪。但他说是把“智慧生命”换成了“女朋友”。
So I think we started to do the calculation on the board. And can you look up what the population of Boston is?
我想我们开始在黑板上做计算了。你能查一下波士顿的人口是多少吗？
Now Dave is asking me to look this up because at this point in our interview I actually made him run the math for me with real numbers that we got from the internet. So he started with the population of Boston, because he and his fellow physics students wanted girlfriends in Boston, where they all lived. The population of Boston, I found online, was a little under 600,000.
大卫现在让我查这个，因为在采访的这一刻，我实际上让他用我们从网上找到的真实数字为我演示了计算过程。所以他从波士顿的人口开始，因为他和他的物理学同学想要在波士顿这个他们居住的地方找女朋友。我上网查到，波士顿的人口略低于60万。
So you start with 600,000, which sounds great, except that half of them are guys, right? And I'm only interested in girls.
所以你从60万开始，这听起来不错，但其中一半是男性，对吧？而我只对女性感兴趣。
OK. So it's 300,000.
好的。所以是30万。
And then I want people-- let's be honest, probably within 10 years of my age or something, right?
然后我想要的人——老实说，大概在和我年龄相差10岁以内的吧，对吧？
OK. So 10 years on either side. So that means--
好的。也就是上下10岁。那意味着——
I'm actually looking at some numbers here. It looks like if you go from 20 to 40, you're talking-- that's still like 35% of the population, a third or something.
我正在看一些数据。看起来如果你选20到40岁之间，你谈论的——那大约仍占总人口的35%，也就是三分之一左右。
So that means that out of 300,000 women, that leaves 100,000 in his age range. These being doctoral students they wanted girlfriends who were college grads. Well, OK. About 25% of Americans over 25 years old have graduated from college. That knocks out roughly three-fourths of these women.
所以这意味着在30万女性中，他这个年龄段的还有10万人。作为博士生，他们想要大学毕业的女朋友。嗯，好吧。25岁以上的美国人中约有25%大学毕业。这排除了大约四分之三的女性。
Ouch.
哎哟。
So you're down to-- we were at 100,000. So you're down to 25,000.
所以你只剩下——我们之前是10万。所以现在只剩下2.5万了。
Then you start applying stuff like, you know, how often are they single?
然后你开始应用一些条件，比如，你知道，她们单身的频率是多少？
Yeah. Let's say half of them are single. So now you're down to 12,500.
对。假设她们中有一半是单身。所以现在只剩下12500人了。
Yeah, see? It's getting scary now, right?
是吧，看？现在开始变得可怕了，对吧？
And then, of course, you get to how many people are actually attractive to you. And even if you give a really high percentage-- like one in five, OK? That knocks your pool of candidates down from 12,500 to 2,500.
然后，当然，还要算上实际上对你有吸引力的人数。即使你给出一个很高的比例——比如五分之一，好吗？这会让你的候选池从12500缩减到2500人。
In the whole city of Boston, right?
在整个波士顿市，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
That's just like a needle in a haystack.
这简直就像大海捞针。
And that 2,500 is before you get to anything personal, like your religion, or how you see the world, what's your sense of humor. So Dave and his fellow students are talking about this-- these rather kind of, you know, depressing numbers. And one of the professors comes in.
而这2500人还没算上任何个人因素，比如你的宗教信仰、你的世界观、你的幽默感。所以大卫和他的同学们正在讨论这些——这些相当令人沮丧的数字。这时一位教授进来了。
She's not married either. And so we start to draw it for her. And then we started to say, well, OK, half of them are men. So we'd circle half. And then we'd say, well, what's the age group you're interested in? And then we'd sort of circle a smaller subset. And then she had all these other requirements, like the guy had to be taller than her-- and she's pretty tall-- so that really limited things.
她也没有结婚。于是我们开始为她画这个计算图。然后我们开始说，好吧，一半是男性。所以我们画了一个圆圈代表一半。然后我们说，那么你感兴趣的年龄段是多少？然后我们画了一个更小的子集。接着她还有其他所有要求，比如那个男人必须比她高——她挺高的——所以这真的限制了很多选择。
And then she said he had to be smarter than her. You know, and she's a Harvard physics professor. So that was even smaller. And basically we got down to there being nobody. [LAUGHS]
然后她说他必须比她聪明。你知道，她可是哈佛的物理学教授。所以范围就更小了。基本上我们最后得出结论，根本没人选。[笑声]
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
She's alone.
她独自一人。
During this period of your life when you would think about these numbers, were you sure the entire time that there was somebody out there?
在你人生中考虑这些数字的这段时间里，你是否一直确信这世上会有那么一个人存在？
Yeah. I don't know why. But, you know, at the beginning of every mathematical proof, people often write, assume that there exists X. [LAUGHS] Assume we have an infinite surface bound by something or whatever. It's like, assume there exists some girlfriend. There is totally that act of faith underneath it. Yeah.
是的。我不知道为什么。但是，你知道，在每个数学证明的开头，人们经常写“假设存在X”。[笑声] 假设我们有一个被某物包围的无限表面之类的。这就像是，假设存在某个女朋友。这完全是一种信仰行为。是的。
But I had a more scientific view, which is that there are people out there, you know, who might be right for me. And not just one person. That seemed like some-- in a silly novel or something. You know?
但我有一个更科学的观点，那就是外面确实有人，你知道，可能适合我。而且不仅仅是一个人。那听起来像是——在愚蠢的小说里才会发生。你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I don't believe there's just one-- if there were just one person out there, good luck! They could speak Chinese, you know? And they probably do, right? What are the odds you're going to find them and the translator? You've got to believe there's more than one person.
我不相信世界上只有一个——如果世界上真的只有一个人，祝你好运！他们可能会说中文，你知道吗？而且他们很可能确实说了，对吧？你找到他们和翻译的几率有多大？你必须相信不止一个人。
Well, today in our program we have stories of people who dare to believe that they have found that one person for them, even if it is just a pleasant lie, that there is just one person out there for each of us. They have chosen to believe that they need to look no further. And then they act on that belief, doing some things, I have to say, I bet you have never heard of people doing.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于那些敢于相信自己已经找到了那唯一一个人的故事，即使这只是一个美好的谎言，即我们每个人在世上都只有那么一个命中注定的人。他们选择相信自己无需再寻找。然后他们根据这种信念采取行动，做一些我敢说你从未听说过的事情。
And they do these things because they just cannot stop themselves. Like every country song ever written would tell you, they have got no choice. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. We first broadcast today's episode in 2013. We're running it again today because Valentine's Day is coming around again.
他们做这些是因为他们无法控制自己。就像所有乡村音乐所写的那样，他们别无选择。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我们于2013年首次播出本期节目。我们今天再次重播，因为情人节又要到了。
The population of Boston has grown since 2013 when we first did this show. It's now almost 700,000. Meaning the odds of finding love there have gotten even worse, if you believe there's just one person for you. So what if that's true? Answers today. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
自2013年我们首次制作这期节目以来，波士顿的人口有所增长。现在几乎达到70万了。这意味着如果你相信世界上只有一个人属于你，那么在那里找到真爱的几率变得更低了。如果那是真的怎么办？今天的节目将为您解答。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, The Best Laid Plans. Well, when you hear it the first couple did-- the thing that they decided to attempt-- I think one of the things that is the most incredible about it is the kind of couple they were when they did this, which is a really great couple.
第一幕，精心策划。嗯，当你听到这对情侣做了什么——他们决定尝试的事情——我认为最令人不可思议的一点是，当他们这样做时，他们是一对什么样的情侣，也就是一对真的很棒的情侣。
We were always like the most solid of all the relationships of our friends and everything like that.
我们总是我们所有朋友中关系最稳固的，诸如此类。
Kurt Braunohler met his girlfriend on the third day of college. And, in all of the ways that we think of what makes a good relationship, I think that they were doing better than you, or me, or most people. They had a lot of fun together. They could talk about anything. They didn't really fight. Happy sex life.
库尔特·布劳诺勒（Kurt Braunohler）在大学第三天就遇到了他的女朋友。而且，在所有我们认为构成良好关系的方面，我认为他们做得比你、我或者大多数人都好。他们在一起很快乐。他们无话不谈。他们几乎不吵架。性生活也很美满。
We really just got along very well together. We traveled well together. You know, we were always the kind of-- we were the place that friends would come when they are having hard times and they would stay with us. And we were kind of-- it felt like very adult. Even when I was 23, I felt like, I'm kind of married, even though neither of us had ever, ever discussed getting married.
我们真的相处得非常好。我们一起去旅行。你知道，我们一直是那种——当朋友们遇到困难时，他们会来我们这里，会和我们待在一起。而且我们感觉——感觉非常成熟。即使在我23岁时，我就觉得，我像是结婚了，尽管我们俩从未讨论过结婚的事。
So what happened?
那后来发生了什么？
Well, after we had both turned 30, one day I just kind of was thinking about why we had never talked about getting married. Like, we had never, ever talked about it seriously or otherwise. And whenever anyone would ask us, we would always just kind of brush it off and say, oh, well, we're going to-- we'll get married when we have kids. That's what we'd always say.
嗯，在我们俩都过了30岁以后，有一天我突然在想为什么我们从来没有谈过结婚的事。就像，我们从来没有认真地或者其他方式谈论过它。每当有人问起我们，我们总是敷衍过去，说，哦，好吧，我们打算——我们要等有了孩子再结婚。这就是我们一直说的。
And I remember we were sitting in the living room and it was October. And I just said, hey, I want to talk. And I said, why-- you know, why do you think we haven't gotten married yet? Or even talked about it? And she just kind of looked at me and thought for a second. And then she said, well, I think that before we get married, we should probably sleep with other people.
我还记得我们坐在客厅里，那是十月。我只是说，嘿，我想谈谈。我说，为什么——你知道，你觉得我们为什么还没结婚呢？甚至都没谈过？她看着我，想了一会儿。然后她说，嗯，我觉得在结婚之前，我们大概应该和其他人睡一觉。
And-- and that-- you would imagine that that would come back as a huge shock to me, like hit me hard. But for some reason, it kind of-- it made sense to me. I kind of was like, OK. Very calmly. And I guess the reason--
然后——然后那——你会认为这会对我造成巨大的冲击，就像猛击我一样。但由于某种原因，它——对我来说说得通。我当时就像，好吧。非常冷静地。我想原因——
Wait, wait. How did that make sense?
等等，等等。这怎么就说得通了？
I've thought a lot about this. And I think that there's a few reasons. We both had this kind of arrogant notion of our relationship-- that it could survive literally anything. That we had been together-- we had known each other our whole adult lives. We were each other's worlds. So really I don't think we thought that we could destroy this thing.
我对此思考了很多。我认为有几个原因。我们俩对我们的关系有一种傲慢的观念——认为它几乎能经受任何考验。我们在一起——我们互相了解了整个成年生活。我们是彼此的世界。所以我真的认为我们从没想过我们会毁掉这段关系。
I talked to the girlfriend, who did not want to come on the radio. And she said basically she'd only had two boyfriends in her life-- her high school boyfriend, who was not a good boyfriend at all, and Kurt, who was great. But she met Kurt, she said, when she was 17. She was 30 when this happened. And she said that she felt like maybe she missed out on something in her 20s, experiences that other people had. And she didn't want to regret that.
我和那位女朋友谈过，她不想上电台。她说基本上她一生中只有过两个男朋友——她的高中男友，那根本不是个好男友，还有库尔特，他很棒。但她说她在17岁时遇到了库尔特。这件事发生时她30岁。她说她觉得也许她在20多岁时错过了什么，错过了别人拥有的那些经历。她不想为此后悔。
A warning, I should say, before we go any further in this story. We're going to acknowledge the existence of sex between adults. Nothing explicit. Anyway, so they sat on the couch, and they talked this through.
在继续讲这个故事之前，我应该先提个醒。我们将承认成年人之间性行为的存在。没有什么露骨的细节。总之，他们坐在沙发上，商量了这件事。
The next part of that conversation was how-- the logistics. Do we break up? Do I move out? Do we just do this while we're living in the same house together? And we kind of came up with this idea of borrowing this Amish concept called rumspringa. And rumspringa in the Amish world is when you're 16, you're allowed to be not Amish for two years. And then when you turn 18, you decide whether or not you come back to the fold.
谈话的下一部分是如何——后勤工作。我们分手吗？我要搬出去吗？我们要住在同一栋房子里时就这样做吗？我们想出了借用阿米什人“青春期漫游”（rumspringa）概念的想法。在阿米什世界里，青春期漫游是指当你16岁时，你可以有两年不当阿米什人。然后当你18岁时，你再决定是否回归。
Right. And during those two years, kids get drunk. They sleep around. They try drugs.
对。在那两年里，孩子们会喝醉。他们会滥交。他们会尝试毒品。
They do lots of meth.
他们会吸很多冰毒。
They do lots of stuff.
他们会做很多事。
So we were going to have-- we decided to have a rumspringa from our relationship. And that's the other crazy thing is that we decided that it-- 30 days was enough. Because probably within 30 days, sleeping with other people would get that all out of our system in 30 days.
所以我们要有——我们决定从我们的关系中进行一次青春期漫游。而另一件疯狂的事是，我们决定30天就够了。因为可能在30天内，和其他人睡觉就能把这些冲动全部排解掉了。
Turns out it's really difficult to all of a sudden become single at 31, when you've never been single for your entire life. Because all of a sudden, I'm in New York City and I'm single, and I essentially have the emotional tools of a 17-year-old boy.
事实证明，在31岁时突然变成单身真的很困难，因为你一辈子从来没单身过。因为突然之间，我身处纽约市，我单身，而我本质上拥有一个17岁男孩的情感工具。
Because the last time you'd dated was-- you were 17.
因为你上次约会时——你才17岁。
The last time I dated I was in a dorm room.
我上次约会是在宿舍里。
Yeah.
是的。
Also it wasn't that I was just-- it wasn't like I was single in New York City. Because being single in New York City is, I think, the majority of it is being just very lonely and being on your own, whereas this was very different. I was in a marathon. I was in a race. I was in-- I was in a 30-day race to sleep with as many people as I possibly could. Because after 30 days, I was going to go back and then get married. So--
而且不仅仅是我——不像我只是在纽约市单身。因为在纽约市单身，我认为大部分时间是感到非常孤独和独自一人，而这次非常不同。我在跑马拉松。我在比赛。我在——我在进行一场30天的比赛，尽可能多地与人睡觉。因为30天后，我就要回去结婚了。所以——
So there's a time clock ticking.
所以有一个时间钟在滴答作响。
Every single-- it was almost to the minute where I'd just be like, if I wasn't out somewhere trying to meet someone, I was like, this is wasted time. I am wasting my time right now. And also because of the fact that we were both-- my girlfriend and I were both very competitive with each other, that we didn't speak during that 30 days.
每一天——几乎精确到分钟，我就想，如果我没有出去试图见某人，我就想，这是在浪费时间。我现在在浪费我的时间。而且因为我们俩——我和我女朋友都非常好胜，所以在30天内我们没有说话。
But I think in both of our minds we had a competitive nature of being like, I need to sleep with more people than she does. And I think she felt the same way.
但我认为我们俩心里都有那种竞争心态，想着，我需要比她睡更多的人。我想她也是这么想的。
That's true. She did feel that way. I asked her. So before they started the rumspringa, they took a last romantic trip together to New Orleans over New Year's. And they had a great time. And then on January 3, after they both cried a bit, Kurt moved out for a month. So, you know, suddenly single, 31, time clock ticking, where do you start, right?
这是真的。她确实是那么想的。我问过她。所以在他们开始青春期漫游之前，他们在新年前夕一起去了新奥尔良进行了一次最后的浪漫旅行。他们玩得很开心。然后在1月3日，在两人都哭过之后，库尔特搬出去住了一个月。所以，你知道，突然单身，31岁，时间在流逝，你要从哪开始呢，对吧？
Well, Kurt called this woman that he knew just a little bit and had a date on the very first or second night. He can't remember which it was. And at a dinner, he told her the entire situation. He laid the whole thing out, that he was seeing somebody. They were taking this break to sleep around. And this was a rule that he made for himself, that he was always going to be honest with any woman that he met during this month. He was going to be honest, upfront.
嗯，库尔特给一个他稍微认识的女人打了电话，并在第一晚或第二晚约会了。他不记得是哪天了。在晚餐时，他把整个情况告诉了她。他把所有事情都摊开来说，他正在和某人交往。他们正在休息以尝试和其他人睡觉。这是他给自己定的规则，他必须对这个月遇到的任何女人保持诚实。他要诚实、坦率。
That-- and that's the weird thing. That's the thing that I still kind of-- when I think back on this time-- that I don't understand. Like, I don't understand how these women that I met during that time heard the story and were like, OK. Let's continue with this date.
那——那是最奇怪的事情。那就是我至今仍然——当我回想起那段时间时——不理解的事情。我不明白我当时遇到的那些女人听到这个故事后是怎么想的，竟然会说，好吧。让我们继续约会吧。
Well, what would they say?
嗯，她们会说什么？
I think most of them-- the overwhelming response was like, wow? And I can't believe you're telling me this.
我想她们大多数人——绝大多数反应是，哇？我不敢相信你告诉我这些。
Kurt was staying on a futon on a friend's living room floor for the month in this apartment where there was no door between the living room and the bedroom where his friend was sleeping. And he brought this woman back on the first date. And they made out a little bit. And then they set another date.
库尔特那个月借住在朋友客厅地板上的折叠沙发上，那间公寓的客厅和朋友睡觉的卧室之间没有门。他在第一次约会时就把那个女人带了回来。他们亲热了一会儿。然后他们又约了一次。
I think it was probably for the next night or the night after. Something like that.
我想可能是第二天晚上或再下一晚。诸如此类的。
And what happens?
然后发生了什么？
What do you mean? What happens on the date?
你是什么意思？约会时发生了什么？
I guess I mean, do you sleep with her? Since the whole point of this story is you trying to sleep with women.
我想我指的是，你和她睡觉了吗？因为这个故事的全部意义就是你试图和其他女人睡觉。
Yes. Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。是的。
I mean, suddenly, I felt very, like, modest about asking. But, yeah, no. Did you sleep--
我是说，突然间，我觉得问这些事很羞涩。但是，不。你睡了吗——
Yes. We ended up sleeping together.
是的。我们最终睡了。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah. It was amazing. It was-- yeah. It totally turned my head around. It really did feel like having experiences like I would imagine I would have had as a teenager. You know? Where sex was this very powerful thing, and it kind of overwhelmed you.
对。这太神奇了。它——完全改变了我的想法。这确实感觉就像我17岁时会有的那些经历。你知道吗？性是一种非常强大的东西，它让你不知所措。
A day or two after that, he picks up a woman in a bar-- something he had never done before in his life. And he goes home with her. And from there, he's off and running. But, remember, he has the emotional tools of a 17-year-old.
那之后一两天，他在酒吧里搭讪了一个女人——这是他一生中从未做过的事。他跟她回家了。从此之后，他一发不可收拾。但是，记住，他只有17岁男孩的情感工具。
I was emotionally getting involved with these women. And that was against one of our rules that we had come up with. My girlfriend and I had had a rule saying, no relationships. We don't get into relationships with people. We're just going to go out and sleep with people to see what it's like.
我在情感上与这些女性产生了纠葛。而这违背了我们想出的规则之一。我和我女朋友有一条规则，即不发展关系。我们不与人建立关系。我们只是出去和其他人睡觉，看看那是什么感觉。
Oh, I see. And then-- but you didn't actually know how to just go out and sleep with somebody without getting emotionally involved.
哦，我明白了。然后——但你实际上并不知道如何在不产生情感纠葛的情况下出去和某人睡觉。
Not at all. I mean, the first date I went on, I immediately was, like, head over heels for her and I knew her for six hours. And I didn't know how to date. I didn't know how to date casually. So what I really was doing was just getting involved-- I was acting like a person who had been in a 13-year relationship with these women that I had just met.
完全不知道。我是说，我去的第一次约会，我就立刻——对她神魂颠倒，尽管我只认识她六个小时。我不知道怎么约会。我不知道怎么随便约会。所以我真正做的是只是产生纠葛——我表现得像是一个和这些我刚认识的女人已经维持了13年关系的人。
Like how does that mean? What do you mean?
那意味着什么？你指的是什么？
Immediately holding hands. I remember that my impulse would be to say, "I love you," during sex. [LAUGHS] That would be my impulse because that's the only way I was used to having sex. And I remember the first time that I did end up having sex, I started to say, I love you, and then just kind of swallowed it and made it seem like I was coughing. [LAUGHS] And that wasn't-- and that didn't happen just once.
立刻牵手。我记得我的冲动是在做爱时说“我爱你”。[笑声] 那会是我的冲动，因为那是做爱时我唯一习惯的方式。我记得第一次最终发生性行为时，我开始说“我爱你”，然后就把它吞了回去，假装是我在咳嗽。[笑声] 而那不是——那不只发生了一次。
Kurt says it was just a month of incredibly intense feelings. He'd feel this crazy elation or he would find himself walking down the street weeping. The girlfriend told me that she, meanwhile, was having escapades of her own. She'd be out all night, drinking and dancing, going to exclusive clubs with Mexican high rollers, doing crazy things with European tourists. It was just what she wanted actually.
库尔特说那是一个充满极度强烈情感的月份。他会感到一种疯狂的狂喜，或者发现自己在街上走着走着就哭了。那位女朋友告诉我，与此同时，她自己也有一些冒险经历。她会整晚都在外面，喝酒跳舞，和墨西哥的大富豪去高级俱乐部，和欧洲游客做疯狂的事情。这实际上正是她想要的。
And both of them told me that the weirdest thing about that time was that the person that they wanted to talk to most about what was going on and share it with was each other. But of course they weren't speaking. Kurt says that one of the most amazing things to him, that was kind of a revelation during that time, was something-- I've never actually heard anybody talk about it out loud, but I totally related to this-- was how quickly he would find himself in the home of a complete stranger.
他们俩都告诉我，那段时间最奇怪的事情是，他们最想与之交流、最想分享这段经历的人正是对方。但当然他们当时没有交谈。库尔特说，对他而言最神奇的事情之一，那种在那段时间里的顿悟，是一些——我从没听过任何人当众谈论过，但我完全感同身受——那就是他发现自己以多快的速度置身于一个完全陌生人的家中。
Yeah. I'd never gotten to see other people's apartments so much. That's kind of what I was fascinating by, getting to see all these different people's apartments and seeing how everyone lives. And I loved that. I loved that part of it so much. You know, it's like-- I was like, look at this. Like, I'm seeing-- this is all your stuff. This is the stuff you keep on your bedside table.
对。我以前从来没有那么多机会看到别人的公寓。这正是我所迷恋的地方，能看到所有这些不同人的公寓，看每个人是怎么生活的。我喜欢那样。我非常喜欢那部分。你知道，就像——我就想，看这个。就像，我正在看——这是你所有的东西。这是你放在床头柜上的东西。
And also having like really weird experiences I'd never had before, like, of like, women picking me up. I never experienced that before. I was so confused. Because it was a bartender. She was, like, a bartender. So she just kept giving me drinks, free drinks. And I was like, why is this person-- why is she giving me all these free drinks?
还有一些我以前从未有过真正奇怪的经历，比如，有女人搭讪我。我以前从未经历过。我太困惑了。因为那是个酒保。她是个酒保。所以她一直在给我酒，免费的酒。我就想，为什么这个人——为什么她一直在给我这么多免费的酒？
But it is fascinating to see if you stay at the bar until 4:00 in the morning, then all of a sudden-- I'd never been aware of it before. But then I started looking around me like, oh, all these people are like pairing off. Look at how this happens. Like I'd never been-- I've been at bars until 4:00 in the morning, but I was always-- it's all of a sudden like uncovering this whole level of single life in New York City that I had-- that I was just-- had not been aware of before.
但如果你在酒吧待到凌晨4点，看看那真的很有趣，然后突然间——我以前从来没意识到过。但我开始环顾四周，心想，哦，所有这些人都像是在配对。看看这是怎么发生的。就像我从来没——我以前也曾在酒吧待到凌晨4点，但我总是——这突然间揭示了纽约市单身生活的整个层面，我以前——我完全没有意识到过。
Anyone in New York City I feel like can have sex any night of the week if they just follow two rules-- which is, stay at the bar until 4:00 in the morning and dramatically lower your standards. [LAUGHS]
我觉得在纽约市，如果遵循两条规则，任何人每天晚上都能发生性行为——那就是，待在酒吧直到凌晨4点，并大幅降低你的标准。[笑声]
So after a month, Kurt and his girlfriend get together and talk. And they agree that a month was not enough for this. They said that it was just obvious the experiment hadn't run its course. They both wanted more time. So they decided on a second month, which then becomes third month. And for Kurt, as time went on, it got harder and harder to stick with the rule that they had made of not getting into any relationships. He's just muddling about, how to figure out how to do that.
所以一个月后，库尔特和他的女朋友见面商量。他们一致认为一个月的时间对此来说不够。他们说实验显然还没有结束。他们都想要更多时间。所以他们决定再增加一个月，然后变成了第三个月。对库尔特来说，随着时间的推移，坚持他们制定的“不发展任何关系”的规则变得越来越难。他只是在瞎混，想弄明白该怎么做。
In his head he would think, like, when is something actually a relationship?
在他的脑海里，他会想，什么时候才算真正的一种关系？
And I think in my head I was like, three dates. Three dates makes a relationship. That's what I defined. And so then I would try to not see people for more than three times. That was increasingly difficult.
我想在我的脑海里，我想的是，三次约会。三次约会就构成了一种关系。这就是我定义的。所以我就试着不和人见超过三次。那越来越困难。
It's difficult because he was giving women two opposite messages at the same time. He would tell them that he was just taking a month's break from his real relationship and this isn't serious. But then, he didn't hold back any of his feelings.
这很困难，因为他同时在给女人们传递两个截然不同的信号。他会告诉她们，他只是从真正的情感关系中休息一个月，这并不严肃。但随后，他又不掩饰自己的任何感受。
What I felt like kept happening was that I would act like I wanted to be their boyfriend, and then after three dates, would just abruptly end it with no explanation whatsoever. And definitely-- definitely people would yell at me and call me names. And I feel-- to this day, I feel horrible about that. Because I was just-- I was acting like a crazy person. I was acting like a person with absolutely no boundaries.
我感觉一直发生的事情是，我会表现得好像我想做她们的男朋友，然后在三次约会后，就毫无理由地突然结束它。绝对——绝对有人会对我大喊大叫，骂我。我感觉——至今我仍为此感到可怕。因为我只是——我表现得像个疯子。我表现得像个完全没有边界的人。
So it was hard to stop himself while it was going on. And when we talked about it, Kurt's best explanation for that was--
所以当这种事发生时，很难阻止自己。当我们谈到这一点时，库尔特最好的解释是——
Well, I once had a-- when I had a dog-- when I was a kid, I had a dog. And one day, the cat knocked a five pound bag of sugar off onto the floor. And my dog was about nine pounds. He was a toy poodle. And he ate all five pounds of sugar in one day. And then he was sick for, like, three days afterwards.
嗯，我曾经有一个——当我养过一只狗的时候——我小的时候，我有一只狗。有一天，猫把一袋五磅的糖推到了地板上。我的狗大约九磅重。它是只玩具贵宾犬。它一天之内吃掉了全部五磅的糖。然后它接下来病了大约三天。
But I always think about that day for him, how amazing that day must have been, like, eating all that sugar, and eating it, and then going away from it for a little while, and being like, I can't stop. When is this going to happen again? And then he just started vomiting and vomiting for three straight days. And that's how I felt, you know? Like, I knew this was bad. But I was like, when is this ever going to happen again?
但我总是想到对它来说那一天，那一天该有多美妙，比如，吃掉所有那些糖，然后离开它一会儿，想着，我停不下来。什么时候才会再发生这种事？然后它就开始呕吐，呕吐了整整三天。我就是那种感觉，你知道吗？就像，我知道这很糟糕。但我心想，这种事怎么可能再发生？
I asked Kurt's girlfriend if all this happened to her during the rumspringa, too-- if it was hard just to have sex without emotion entering into it at all. And she said, absolutely not. Quote, "You mean the dudes that I meet at bars, or parties, whatever? Those people?" She said, "I didn't tell anyone anything about my background or the situation."
我问库尔特的女朋友在青春期漫游期间这一切是否也发生在她身上——是否很难在没有情感介入的情况下只发生性关系。她说，绝对不会。她说，“你是说我在酒吧或派对上遇到的那些男人吗？那些人？” 她说，“我没告诉任何人我的背景或情况。”
And I asked her, wait, so you wouldn't explain, I'm on a break from a relationship? She said, "No, because it sounds crazy." I told her that Kurt would reveal all of that, which she knew. And she said, yeah, yeah, Kurt's way too open. But, quote, "That openness probably just made him more appealing to the ladies."
我问她，等等，那你不会解释说，我正处于一段关系的空窗期吗？她说，“不会，因为那听起来很疯狂。” 我告诉她库尔特会透露所有这些，她是知道的。她说，是的，是的，库尔特太坦率了。但是，引用她说的话，“那种坦率可能反而让他对女士们更具吸引力。”
By the end of three months, Kurt started to fall for this woman that he met in Australia. And this time, really actually fall for her in a real way. And this made him, of course, feel differently about his relationship with his girlfriend. So he flew back to the States, stayed at their old apartment, and because this is the most comfortable relationship that has ever existed between two people, of course, they dealt with it all right away. Very straightforward.
三个月结束时，库尔特开始爱上他在澳大利亚遇到的那个女人。而这一次，是真正意义上的爱。这让他对和女朋友的关系有了不同的感受。所以他飞回了美国，住在他们原来的公寓里，因为这是两个人之间有史以来最舒服的关系，当然，他们立刻处理了所有事情。非常直截了当。
And we woke up in the morning and we went and got brunch. And we brought it to the park, the way we'd always used to do on Saturdays. And we just sat in the park and talked. And we broke up. And that's the thing. I can't I can't point to something that was bad about our relationship, except for knowing that I feel like it had run its course.
我们早上醒来去吃了早午餐。我们把它带到公园，就像我们以前周六习惯做的那样。我们只是坐在公园里交谈。然后我们分手了。这就是事情的经过。我不能——我不能指出我们关系中有什么不好的地方，除了知道我感觉它已经走到了尽头。
I mean, we organically got to the point where we both thought this was a good idea.
我是说，我们自然而然地达到了我们俩都认为这是个好主意的地步。
This-- the rumspringa?
这个——那个青春期漫游吗？
It's almost like we-- the relationship had an expiration date, but we didn't know about it. And then all of a sudden, we came up with this really complicated, crazy plan to put the test down at the right place where it would break. And it broke.
这简直就像我们——这段关系有一个保质期，但我们不知道。然后突然之间，我们想出了一个非常复杂、疯狂的计划，把测试放在了它会破裂的地方。然后它就破裂了。
His old girlfriend said something similar. She said she'd probably wanted out of the relationship before the rumspringa, but she was just too scared to admit it to herself. The rumspringa gave them a way to break up. Kurt says he would not want to do a rumspringa again. But he came out of this experience believing that it is important to force things to a decision with someone, and that it's healthy for any relationship to be evaluated now and then.
他的前女友也说了类似的话。她说她可能在青春期漫游之前就想结束这段关系，但她太害怕承认了。青春期漫游给他们提供了一种分手的方式。库尔特说他不想再进行一次青春期漫游了。但他从这次经历中得出结论，重要的是要强迫自己与某人做出决定，而且偶尔对每一段关系进行评估是健康的。
I do have a theory now. I do have a theory about if I do get married in the future. What I think I would want to do is have an agreement that, at the end of seven years, we have to get remarried in order for the marriage to continue. But at the end of seven years, it ends. And we can agree to get remarried or not get remarried.
我现在确实有一个理论。如果我将来结婚，我有一个理论。我想做的是达成一个协议，即在七年后，我们必须重新结婚，婚姻才能继续。但七年后，它就结束了。我们可以同意重新结婚，或者不同意。
Why?
为什么？
Because then I get-- I think you get to choose. And I think it makes the relationship-- would make the relationship stronger.
因为那样我就能——我认为你拥有了选择的权利。我认为这会让关系——会让关系变得更强。
I don't know what I think of that because I think, actually, one of the things that's a comfort in marriage is that there isn't a door at seven years. And so if something is messed up in the short term, there's a comfort of knowing, like, well, we made this commitment. And so we're just going to work this out. Like, if even if tonight we're not getting along or there's something between us that doesn't feel right, you have the comfort of knowing, like, we've got time.
我不知道我怎么看这个，因为我认为，实际上，婚姻的一种安慰在于七年后没有一道门。所以如果短期内出了问题，有一种安慰感，比如，嗯，我们做了这个承诺。所以我们只是要解决它。就像，即使今晚我们相处得不好，或者我们之间有什么感觉不对劲的地方，你有一种安慰感，知道，嗯，我们有时间。
We're going to figure this out. And that makes it so much easier. Because you do go through, like, times when you hate each other's guts. You know what I mean? Like--
我们会解决这个问题的。这让一切变得容易多了。因为你确实会经历比如互相厌恶的时候。你知道我的意思吗？就像——
Of course you do. Yeah.
你当然会。对。
And the no escape clause, weirdly, is a bigger comfort to being married than I ever would have thought, before I got married.
而没有逃跑条款，奇怪的是，这对婚姻的安慰比我结婚前想象的要大得多。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
对。
I never thought of it that way.
我从来没那样想过。
Yeah. It's--
对。它是——
I like thinking about it that way. You just see so many examples of where that-- of people-- where people don't think that way.
我喜欢那样思考。你看到太多例子，人们——人们不是那样思考的。
Both Kurt and his girlfriend feel like the rumspringa got them where they needed to go as a couple, even if that place was different than they intended when they began the whole thing. Sometimes what you need to do next as a couple you can't even tell what it should be. And the best you can do is hold your breath, make a guess, and jump.
库尔特和他的女朋友都觉得青春期漫游作为一对情侣让他们达到了他们需要去的地方，即使那个地方与他们刚开始整个事情时所预想的不同。有时你作为一对情侣接下来需要做什么，你甚至无法分辨应该是什么。而你能做的最好的事情就是屏住呼吸，猜一猜，然后跳下去。
It's actually been a few years since we first broadcast this story. Today's show is a rerun. Kurt and his girlfriend are now both happily married to other people, and each separately have children. Things worked out fine. Kurt's on the TV show Black Monday and does stand up around the country, including this weekend at the Crocodile in Seattle. His tour schedule is at kurtbraunohler.com.
距离我们首次播出这个故事已经过去几年了。今天的节目是重播。库尔特和他的女朋友现在都快乐地与其他人结婚，并且各自有了孩子。事情进展得很顺利。库尔特参加了电视节目《黑色星期一》，并在全国各地表演脱口秀，包括本周末在西雅图的鳄鱼咖啡馆（The Crocodile）。他的巡演时间表在kurtbraunohler.com上。
[MUSIC - "30 DAYS" BY RUN DMC]
[音乐 - RUN DMC的《30 DAYS》]
Coming up, love stories between a kid and someone who is not a kid, and a duck and someone who is not a duck, and Mike Birbiglia and someone who is not Mike Birbiglia. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，关于一个孩子和一个不是孩子的人，一只鸭子和一个不是鸭子的人，以及迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）和一个不是迈克·比比利亚的人之间的爱情故事。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, for Valentine's Day, stories about people who believe in love, who believe they have found someone for them, and who take action. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, 21 Chump Street.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，为了情人节，故事讲述了那些相信爱情、相信自己找到了命中注定的人，并采取行动的人。我们现在进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，21条笨蛋街（21 Chump Street）。
A couple of years ago, at three high schools in Palm Beach County, Florida, a bunch of young police officers were sent undercover to pose as students. These were recent graduates of the police cadet program, and they blended right in. They went to classes, they ate in the cafeteria. They hung out on the basketball court during recess. They had fake Facebook accounts, of course. They even took the state's standardized test, the FCAT.
几年前，在佛罗里达州棕榈滩县的三所高中，一群年轻的警官被派往学校卧底，冒充学生。他们是警察学员项目的应届毕业生，看起来完全融入了学校。他们去上课，在食堂吃饭。他们在课间休息时在篮球场晃悠。他们当然有虚假的Facebook账号。他们甚至参加了州标准化的FCAT考试。
Police officers were there undercover because parents and principals had complained about drugs being sold at the schools. Only the principals at the schools knew of their presence. No teachers knew it. No parents knew it. Now, maybe it is hard to imagine a love story coming out of this situation, but one did. A love story where somebody went out of his way, and took action at a key moment for love.
警察之所以去卧底，是因为家长和校长投诉学校有人在卖毒品。只有学校的校长知道他们的存在。没有老师知道。没有家长知道。现在，也许很难想象这种情况会产生爱情故事，但确实发生了。一个某人为了爱情在关键时刻不惜一切代价、采取行动的爱情故事。
We've told this story twice on our program. Once we turned it into a musical, once as straight reporting. That's what you're about to hear-- the straight reporting version. Robbie Brown was a reporter with the New York Times when he first looked into this.
我们在节目中讲过两次这个故事。一次我们把它改编成了音乐剧，一次是直接报道。这就是你即将听到的——直接报道版本。罗比·布朗（Robbie Brown）是《纽约时报》的记者，他首次调查了这件事。
The plan was called Operation D-Minus. And one of the schools included in the plan was Park Vista Community High School, where a kid named Justin LaBoy, an 18-year-old honor roll student, was in the last semester of his senior year. And Justin could hardly believe his luck when a very pretty new girl-- everyone had noticed her-- showed up in not just one, but two of his classes.
该计划被称为“D-Minus行动”。该计划包括的学校之一是公园景观社区高中（Park Vista Community High School），一个名叫贾斯汀·拉博伊（Justin LaBoy）的孩子，一个18岁的优等生，当时正处于高三的最后一个学期。当一个非常漂亮的新女孩——大家都注意到了她——出现在他的不止一门，而是两门课上时，贾斯汀简直不敢相信自己的运气。
The name that she used was Naomi. I think it was Naomi Rodriguez. And she sat in front of me, but then I sat next to her. So I started talking to her. Oh, hey. My name is Justin, you know? Oh, I'm Naomi. I'm from New York. This and that. Oh, really? Me too. And I had a hat that said New York on it, too, because I was trying to show her that I wasn't lying or faking it.
她用的名字是娜奥米。我想是娜奥米·罗德里格斯。她坐在我前面，但后来我坐在了她旁边。所以我开始和她交谈。哦，嘿。我叫贾斯汀，你知道吗？哦，我是娜奥米。我来自纽约。这那的。哦，真的吗？我也是。我当时也戴着一顶写着“纽约”的帽子，因为我想向她证明我没有在撒谎或装腔作势。
She said she was from Queens. I'm from the Bronx. And she was Puerto Rican and Dominican. And that's what caught me even more. I was like, oh, man. OK. And then I was Puerto Rican, and I was talking to her a little Spanish. And she talked to me a little Spanish. And then we just-- I just got really close to her. I got attached real quick. I was like, wow, look at this, you know?
她说她来自皇后区。我来自布朗克斯。而且她是波多黎各人和多米尼加人。这更吸引我了。我当时想，噢，伙计。好吧。然后我是波多黎各人，我和她说了点西班牙语。她也跟我说了点西班牙语。然后我们就——我就和她非常亲近了。我很快就粘上了她。我就想，哇，看看这个，你知道吗？
What did she look like?
她长什么样？
She was about 5'4, black straight hair, light skinned. She was mature in the body-wise. So I mean, that caught a lot of people's attention. But the things that she did that I thought that made her a real student was that she would sleep in class. She wouldn't do her homework. I would have to wake her up all the time. Be like, hey, listen. Wake up. You're going to get in trouble. Hey, oh, you didn't do your homework? OK, I'll let you copy my homework. OK.
她大约5英尺4英寸，黑色直发，皮肤白皙。她在身体上很成熟。所以，我是说，这吸引了很多人的注意力。但我认为她作为一名真正的学生所做的事情是，她会在课堂上睡觉。她不做作业。我得一直叫醒她。就像，嘿，听着。醒醒。你会惹麻烦的。嘿，哦，你没做作业？好的，我让你抄我的作业。好的。
Because I mean, I take my classes, you know, seriously, you know? But with her? It was different. I was just like, oh, man. You know, wow, you know. She's cute. I could talk to her, you know? I'll get in trouble once in a while. They'd be like, Justin, stop talking. I'd be like, OK.
因为我是说，我认真对待我的课程，你知道吗？但对她？那不一样。我只是想，哦，伙计。你知道，哇，你知道。她很可爱。我可以和她说话，你知道吗？我会偶尔惹麻烦。他们会说，贾斯汀，别说话。我会说，好的。
Justin's a good looking guy, popular and well-liked. He'd had girlfriends before, but nothing that lasted. Nothing that seemed worth holding on to. But Naomi seemed different. She was a good listener. She didn't seem to gossip or play games. She seemed very adult.
贾斯汀是个长相帅气的家伙，受欢迎且人缘好。他以前交过女朋友，但没有一段能长久。没什么值得留恋的。但娜奥米似乎不同。她是个很好的倾听者。她似乎不爱说长道短或玩弄手段。她看起来非常成熟。
It's the maturity level that I really cared for. And-- OK, I told her a lot of my feelings. You know, I told her how I felt for her. I mean, I'm not the type of person to open up to you unless we have a really good relationship. And [LAUGHS] I was just opening up so much. And I told her about all my whole life story, about my parents. I told the problems I had.
这是我真正关心的成熟度。而且——好吧，我告诉了她很多我的感受。你知道，我告诉了她我对她的感觉。我是说，除非我们有非常好的关系，否则我不是那种会向你敞开心扉的人。而且[笑声]我只是敞开了那么多。我告诉了她我所有的生活故事，关于我的父母。我告诉了她我遇到的问题。
What was it about her that made you trust her? That made you feel like you could open up to her?
她有什么特质让你信任她？让你觉得你可以向她敞开心扉？
She had told me that she lived-- she came up here with her mother, that they was having problems in New York. So you know, they came over here to Florida to settle down, to have a better life. And little stuff like that, to telling people, I believe that, oh, wow. You know, OK, since you're telling me stuff like this, then I could tell you about my life. Yeah. You know, I'm having hard troubles with this person right here. Or I'm having trouble with my parents, or stuff-- little stuff like that makes people bond together, you know?
她告诉我她住——她和她母亲来到这里，她们在纽约遇到了问题。所以你知道，她们来到佛罗里达是为了安顿下来，过上更好的生活。像这样的小事，告诉人们，我相信，哦，哇。你知道，好的，既然你告诉了我这样的事，那么我也可以告诉你关于我的生活。是的。你知道，我在这儿正和一个某人遇到大麻烦。或者我和父母之间有麻烦，或者诸如此类的小事让人们结成纽带，你知道吗？
Justin believed he was seeing signs that Naomi was starting to like him-- like him, like him. They walked together in the halls. They would text during class. He says she even let him kiss her on the cheek. And he serenaded her in front of their entire class.
贾斯汀相信他看到了娜奥米开始喜欢他的迹象——喜欢他，喜欢他。他们在走廊里一起走。他们会在课上发短信。他说她甚至让他亲了她的脸颊。他还当着全班的面为她唱了小夜曲。
I'd be like, oh, I'm going to sing you a song. She'd be like, oh, OK. And then I'll just start singing. And then I'll get all blushed up. I'll be like, ah, man, what am I doing? OK. Let me continue. I'll start rapping to her, and I'll start singing. And I mean, I even danced, too. So I danced for her, and I did--
我会说，哦，我要为你唱首歌。她会说，哦，好的。然后我就开始唱。然后我变得满脸通红。我会想，啊，伙计，我在做什么？好的。让我继续。我会开始给她说唱，我会开始唱歌。我是说，我甚至还跳舞。所以我为她跳舞，我做了——
You really liked this girl.
你真的很喜欢这个女孩。
Man, it tore me apart. I was like, oh my god.
伙计，它把我撕裂了。我当时想，我的天哪。
So you felt like all the signs-- all the signs were good.
所以你觉得所有的迹象——所有的迹象都是好的。
Oh, of course. I felt all the signs were good because I never got a diss-- a non-sign. So, therefore, I was just like, OK. Everything's good. You know, I know I'm taking it slow. You know, I know I'm taking it good. You know, usually it doesn't take me that long to get a girlfriend when I start talking to them.
哦，当然。我感觉所有的迹象都是好的，因为我从来没得到过一个否定的信号。所以，因此，我只是觉得，好吧。一切都很好。你知道，我知道我在慢慢来。你知道，我知道我处理得很好。你知道，通常我开始和女生交谈时，不需要花那么久就能交到女朋友。
So when it took me-- I found it kind of odd that, you know, I was like, wow, you know, I'm such a great dude, and, you know, we're hanging out, you know? What's the next step, you know? I don't care about sex, or anything. I just want to know if you're going to be mine.
所以当我花——我觉得有点奇怪，你知道，我当时想，哇，你知道，我是这么好的家伙，而且，你知道，我们在一起玩，你知道？下一步是什么，你知道吗？我不关心性，或者任何事情。我只是想知道你是否会成为我的。
So she was playing kind of hard to get?
所以她在玩欲擒故纵？
Yes. Yes. I mean, me, I love that. So it attracted me even more. I was like, oh, my-- I love girls that guys can't have. So I'm like, oh, this is awesome.
是的。是的。我是说，我，我喜欢那样。所以它更吸引我了。我就想，噢，我的——我喜欢男生追不到的女生。所以我心想，噢，这太棒了。
And in hindsight, she was probably playing hard to get for a different reason.
事后看来，她玩欲擒故纵可能是有别的原因。
Yes, for a different reason, you know?
是的，有别的原因，你知道吗？
All of this built up, inevitably, to Justin asking Naomi to prom.
这一切必然发展到贾斯汀邀请娜奥米参加舞会。
Yeah. You know, she's a senior. I'm a senior. Our last year. I don't know where we're going to be after this. So let me just step up, and be a man, and do what I got do. So I went up to her in class and I was like, listen, you know, I know you don't know anybody in this school that much. And I don't want to go with anybody in the school. And you know, I feel really attracted to you. Would you like to come with me to prom?
是的。你知道，她是高三。我是高三。我们的最后一年。我不知道在这之后我们会去哪里。所以让我站出来，做一个男人，做我该做的事。所以我上课时走到她身边，我说，听着，你知道，我知道你在这个学校不太认识人。而且我不想和学校里的任何人一起去。而且你知道，我对你真的很着迷。你想和我一起去参加舞会吗？
Oh, that sounds nice. OK. Excuse me, let me think about it. I was blushing red. I was like, oh, my god. What if she says no? What if she says yes? And after she gave me the OK, yeah, you know, around the more of a yes side, I was-- OK. I was good. Good.
哦，那听起来不错。好的。打扰一下，让我考虑一下。我脸红了。我心想，噢，我的天哪。如果她说不怎么办？如果她说好怎么办？在她给了我肯定的回答后，是的，你知道，大概算是肯定的那一边，我——好的。我很好。很好。
You know, prom was coming up and-- I mean, I guess he needed a date. [LAUGHS]
你知道，舞会快到了，而且——我想他大概需要一个舞伴。[笑声]
I interviewed the undercover officer who played Naomi. She's a 25-year-old new recruit with the Palm Beach school's police force. She wouldn't give me her real name, and only agreed to a phone interview, if her supervising sergeant could listen in. She wouldn't talk to me about any specific cases or kids at the school, including Justin. But she did confirm that she was asked to prom. She doesn't remember it quite the way Justin does, though. Mainly, she says she didn't say yes.
我采访了那个扮演娜奥米的卧底警官。她是棕榈滩学校警察局的一名25岁的新兵。她不愿给我她的真实姓名，并且只有在她的监制警长在场监听的情况下才同意电话采访。她拒绝跟我谈论任何具体的案件或学校里的孩子，包括贾斯汀。但她确实证实了她被邀请参加舞会。不过她对那件事的记忆和贾斯汀的不太一样。主要是，她说她没答应。
I told him I wasn't going, just because-- since this is not where I spent the last three years of high school, I didn't really want to go to the prom. And I had to pay for the ticket and everything else, so I was like, nah, it's too much money for me. And he bought it. [LAUGHS]
我告诉他我不去，只是因为——既然我没有在这里度过高中的最后三年，我真的不想去参加舞会。而且我得付门票钱和其他一切费用，所以我当时想，不，对我来说太多钱了。然后他就信了。[笑声]
Justin and Naomi didn't end up going to prom, of course, partly because of what happened next. One day at the beginning of April, after Naomi had been at school for about three months, she and Justin had a conversation about drugs.
贾斯汀和娜奥米当然没能去成舞会，部分原因是接下来发生的事情。四月初的一天，在娜奥米在学校待了大约三个月后，她和贾斯汀聊到了毒品。
She asked me if I smoked. And I told her, no, I do not smoke. But if you need anything, I'll be more than happy to help you out. So you know, like I said, I'm not a drug dealer. I don't-- it's hard for me to get drugs at all. So it's not like she told me this day, and then I got it for her the very next day. You know, it took me a while, you know?
她问我抽不抽烟。我告诉她，不，我不抽烟。但如果你需要什么，我很乐意帮忙。所以你知道，正如我所说，我不是毒贩。我不——我很难搞到毒品。所以并不是她说的那天，我就在第二天立刻就帮她搞到了。你知道，花了我一段时间，你知道？
She would text me, and I would text her. She would be like, do you have it yet? No, I don't have it at the moment right now. And she'll be at school, hey, do you have that yet? No, I don't have it right now. I'm sorry. You know, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm really trying like my hardest to get it. And I can't get it, you know, because I like the girl, so--
她会给我发短信，我也会给她发短信。她会问，你搞到了吗？不，我目前还没有。而她在学校时，嘿，你搞到了吗？不，我现在还没有。我很抱歉。你知道，我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我真的在尽我最大的努力去搞到。但我搞不到，你知道，因为我喜欢这个女孩，所以——
What are you thinking as you're trying to get this pot to sell to her?
你在试图搞到这些大麻去卖给她时，你在想什么？
I'm thinking, what the heck am I doing? [LAUGHS] Like I never-- I never done this in this school before. So I'm really scared and skeptical about it, too, at the same point. And I'm like, oh, man. OK. OK. So I'm asking my homeboy. And my friend's like, no, I don't know-- I don't know because I don't hang out with guys like that.
我在想，我到底在干什么？[笑声] 我以前从没在学校里干过这种事。所以我当时也很害怕和怀疑。我就想，噢，伙计。好的。好的。所以我问了我的好哥们。我朋友说，不，我不知道——我不知道，因为我不和那种家伙混在一起。
Maybe Justin didn't know guys like that and maybe he did. The police say he told Naomi he smoked pot. Justin says he was just trying to seem cool to impress her. But what's certain is he did find somebody who would sell to him-- a person his cousin knew, he says. So a couple days after they first talked about it, Justin brought a rolled up baggie of marijuana to school for Naomi.
也许贾斯汀不知道那种家伙，也许他知道。警方说他告诉娜奥米他抽大麻。贾斯汀说他只是想装酷来给娜奥米留下好印象。但可以肯定的是，他确实找到了一个愿意卖给他的人——他说那是他表弟认识的人。所以就在他们第一次聊到这个话题的几天后，贾斯汀带了一小袋大麻到学校给娜奥米。
And I was petrified. I was like, oh, my god. I'm actually going to do this. So we was in class. And I sat right next to her, and she was like, hey, do you have that? And I was like, you know what? Yeah, I do. And I was like, OK, we're going to wait in a few. We're going to wait a few. Because I'm not going to be like, oh, hey, give it to her in her hand, slide it to her.
我当时吓呆了。我就想，噢，我的天哪。我真的要这么做了。当时我们在上课。我坐在她旁边，她说，嘿，你带了吗？我就说，你知道吗？是的，我带了。我说，好的，我们要等一下。我们要等一下。因为我不会像，哦，嘿，直接交给她，递给她。
But she was like, OK. Put it in my purse. OK. She put her purse on top of my desk. And then I put-- slid it right in there She goes, OK. Now take the money. I was like, no, I don't need the money. It's OK. Just have it. You can take it. She goes, no, please. Take the money. You know, you make me feel bad.
但她说，好的。放在我的包里。好的。她把包放在我的课桌上。然后我把——直接滑进去了。她说，好的。现在拿钱。我说，不，我不需要钱。没关系。留着吧。你可以拿去。她说，不，求你了。拿钱。你知道，你让我感到难过。
So 10 minutes passed, and then we're still arguing about it. I'm like, please. No, I don't want the money, you know? And she goes, no, just take the money. Take the money. Please, take the money. It would make me feel better. I'm just like, OK, you know what? Just so you could just shut up, I'll take the money, you know? Don't worry, you know? You're making me feel bad now that I'm taking money from you.
所以十分钟过去了，我们还在争论这件事。我说，拜托。不，我不想要钱，你知道吗？她说，不，拿钱吧。拿钱。拜托，拿钱。那会让我感觉好点。我就想，好的，你知道吗？为了让你闭嘴，我会收下钱的，你知道吗？别担心，你知道吗？你让我感到难过，因为我正在拿你的钱。
How much money?
多少钱？
$25.
25美元。
And this was at school?
这是在学校里？
Yes.
是的。
Justin would later find out it's a felony in Florida to sell marijuana. And the penalty is even harsher for selling it on school property. In other words, Justin had made an irreversibly bad decision. The worst decision of his life, he says. And since he was over 18, he was legally an adult when he made it.
贾斯汀后来才知道，在佛罗里达州贩卖大麻是重罪。在学校内贩卖惩罚更重。换句话说，贾斯汀做出了一个不可挽回的错误决定。他说这是他人生中最糟的决定。由于他已经18岁了，他在做这个决定时在法律上已经是一个成年人。
Finally, in May, the police did a big sweep. They arrested 31 people at several schools, almost all of them students who had sold small amounts of marijuana. Justin was one of them.
最后，在五月份，警方进行了一次大规模突击搜查。他们在几所学校逮捕了31人，几乎全部是出售少量大麻的学生。贾斯汀就是其中之一。
And they said that I had sold to the undercover cop. And I'm-- I'm weirded out. I'm like, whoa, who did I ever sell to? And then it just popped into my head that the only person that I ever did give anything to was this female. And I was just-- I was shocked. I was-- I-- my emotions were running. And I was just like, oh, my god. This is so mean. This is all messed up. How can she do this, you know?
他们说我卖给了卧底警察。我——我感到很怪异。我就想，哇，我到底卖给过谁？然后脑海里突然蹦出，我唯一给过东西的人就是这个女学生。我当时——我很震惊。我——我——我的情绪在波动。我就想，噢，我的天哪。这太卑鄙了。这一切太混乱了。她怎么能这样做，你知道吗？
I mean, if it was a guy doing this, if a guy ever tried to come up to me like this, I would have put him-- put my hand in his face, straight up and said, no. Get out of my face. Please, get out of my face. I don't associate with that, you know? But it's just the female-- it's a different feeling that you get for female than you would when you have your homeboy, or a guy come up to you and ask you a question like that. Oh, hey. Do you smoke? No, no, I don't. Get out of here.
我是说，如果是男生这样做，如果有什么家伙敢试图这样向我走来，我会让他——我会直接把手甩在他脸上，直截了当地说，不。从我面前消失。拜托，从我面前消失。我不搞那些东西，你知道吗？但这就是女性——你对女性的感觉和你面对你的哥们或男生走过来问你这种问题时的感觉是不同的。哦，嘿。你抽烟吗？不，不，我不抽。滚开。
It was a different feeling that when you get from a girl you like, you know, you're not going to turn down your-- the person that you want to be with.
那种感觉和你喜欢的女生走过来是不同的，你知道，你不会拒绝——你想要与之在一起的人。
When I talked to the officer who plays Naomi, she said she had no regrets about her undercover work. She's a cop, and she sees it the way a cop does.
当我采访那位扮演娜奥米的警官时，她说她对自己的卧底工作没有任何遗憾。她是警察，她是以警察的方式看待问题的。
These kids need to wake up. They need to realize they can't be doing this.
这些孩子需要清醒过来。他们需要意识到他们不能做这种事。
And using undercover officers has gotten results. The police in Palm Beach County tried the same tactics again at another group of schools last semester. So far, they've arrested more than 80 people. All have plead guilty to charges ranging from selling cocaine and pills to bringing weapons on school property.
而使用卧底警官已经取得了效果。棕榈滩县的警方上学期在另一组学校中再次尝试了同样的策略。到目前为止，他们已经逮捕了80多人。所有人都承认了从贩卖可卡因、药丸到在校内携带武器等各项指控。
Justin took a plea deal-- three years probation in exchange for pleading guilty to the felony charge. His lawyer told him that if he went to trial, it would be his word against Naomi's. And they disagreed about the drug deal. He says she kept asking him to sell her marijuana. She says he brought it up first. He says she insisted he take money for it. She says he just took the money without prompting.
贾斯汀接受了控辩交易——承认重罪指控以换取三年的缓刑。他的律师告诉他，如果他上庭，那将是他的一面之词对峙娜奥米。他们对毒品交易有分歧。他说她一直要求他卖给她大麻。她说他先提出来的。他说她坚持让他收钱。她说他未经怂恿就直接拿了钱。
Either way, the police had Justin's text messages telling Naomi he would get marijuana for her. So Justin's lawyer advised him, just take the plea. But before the deal came through, he spent more than a week in jail, going over and over in his mind what had happened, and still thinking in spite of himself about Naomi.
不管怎样，警方有贾斯汀发给娜奥米的短信，说他会帮她搞到大麻。所以贾斯汀的律师建议他直接认罪。但在达成交易之前，他在监狱里待了一周多，在脑海里一遍又一遍地复盘发生的事情，而且尽管如此，他还是在想娜奥米。
I would have a good time when I would be with her. And I would be with her, like, all the time. And that's why when all this collapsed and caved in, I felt-- I felt so like-- it just hurt.
我和她在一起时会玩得很开心。我几乎一直和她在一起。这就是为什么当这一切崩塌、陷落时，我感到——我感到非常——它真的伤害了我。
Have you had any contact with Naomi--
你和娜奥米有过任何联系吗——
No, not--
没有，没有——
--since you were arrested?
——在你被捕之后？
Not at all.
完全没有。
Have you tried to send her any messages?
你试过给她发任何信息吗？
No. I don't have any contact with her whatsoever. If I would, I would love to have a conversation with her. You know? And no disrespect, or anything.
没有。我和她没有任何联系。如果我有，我很乐意和她谈谈。你知道吗？而且没有任何不敬的意思。
What would you tell her?
你会告诉她什么？
I would tell her, what the heck did she do? [LAUGHS]
我会告诉她，她到底干了什么？[笑声]
Justin had planned to go into the Air Force after high school. He said he wanted to make something out of his life. Now with a felony conviction, the armed forces, any part of it, was off the table. Justin is applying to community college. He says now the whole thing seems kind of unbelievable. He was an honor roll student, a first time offender, with no criminal record. And of all the high schools, in all the towns in all the world, she walked into his.
贾斯汀曾计划高中毕业后参军。他说他想在人生中做出一番事业。现在有了重罪记录，武装部队的任何部门都对他关上了大门。贾斯汀正在申请社区大学。他说现在整件事看起来简直不可思议。他曾是一名优等生，初犯，没有任何犯罪记录。而在世界上所有的城镇里，所有的学校中，她偏偏走进了他的那一所。
Robbie Brown, these days he works at Bloomberg Media. Regular listeners to our program know the composer Lin-Manuel Miranda wrote a mini musical based on the story that you just heard. And it's really something. A video of it is at our website, ThisAmericanLife.org.
罗比·布朗，他现在在彭博媒体工作。我们节目的常客都知道，作曲家林-曼努埃尔·米兰达（Lin-Manuel Miranda）根据你们刚刚听到的故事写了一部迷你音乐剧。那真的很棒。视频可以在我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org 上观看。
Act Three, Cold Stone Dreamery. This next story, like that last one we just heard, is about a guy who yearns for someone-- yearns-- and this someone is not giving him much back. This story is from Ben Loory.
第三幕，冷石梦境。接下来的这个故事，就像我们刚才听到的上一个，讲述了一个渴望某人——渴望——而那个人并没有给他太多回馈的家伙。这个故事来自本·卢里（Ben Loory）。
A duck fell in love with a rock. It was a large rock-- about the size of a duck, actually, that was situated off the bank of the river, a little past the old elm. Every day after lunch, the duck would saunter off to admire the rock for a while.
一只鸭子爱上了一块石头。那是一块很大的石头——实际上大约有鸭子那么大，坐落在河岸边，就在老榆树后面。每天午饭后，鸭子就会溜出去欣赏那块石头一会儿。
Where are you going? said the other ducks. Nowhere, said the duck. Just around.
你要去哪？其他鸭子问。哪也不去，鸭子说。只是到处转转。
But the other ducks knew exactly where he was going and they all laughed at him behind his back. Stupid duck is in love with a rock, they snickered. Wonder what kind of ducklings they will have.
但其他鸭子非常清楚他要去哪，他们在背后嘲笑他。笨鸭子爱上了一块石头，他们嗤之以鼻。想知道它们会生出什么样的鸭宝宝。
But there was one duck-- a girl duck-- who did not laugh. She had known the strange duck for a long time and had always found him to be a good and decent bird. She felt sorry for him. It was hard luck to fall in love with a rock. She wanted to help, but what could she do?
但有一只鸭子——一只母鸭子——没有笑。她认识这只奇怪的鸭子很长时间了，一直觉得他是一只好鸟。她为他感到遗憾。爱上一块石头真是倒霉。她想帮忙，但她能做什么呢？
She trailed after the duck and watched him woo the rock from behind a tree. I love you, the duck was saying. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you more than the stars in the sky. I love you more than the fish in the river. I love you more than-- more than-- and there he stopped, for he could think of nothing else that existed.
她跟在鸭子后面，躲在一棵树后看着他追求石头。我爱你，鸭子在说。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你超过天上的星星。我爱你超过河里的鱼。我爱你超过——超过——然后他停住了，因为他想不出还有什么别的东西存在。
Life itself? said the girl duck from behind the tree. She hadn't meant to pipe up. The words just sort of leaped out of her. The duck spun around to look at her. He was terrified.
生命本身呢？躲在树后的母鸭子说。她并没有打算插嘴。这些话只是蹦了出来。鸭子转过身去看她。他吓坏了。
It's OK, said the girl duck, waddling out from behind the tree. I know you're in love with the rock. In fact, everyone knows.
没关系，母鸭子说着，从树后摇摇摆摆地走出来。我知道你爱上了那块石头。事实上，大家都知道。
They do? said the duck. Yes, said the girl duck. Yes, they do. The duck sighed and sat down on the ground. If he had had hands, he would have buried his head in them. What am I going to do? he said. What am I going to do?
他们知道？鸭子说。是的，母鸭子说。是的，他们知道。鸭子叹了口气，坐在地上。如果他有手，他会把头埋在手里。我该怎么办？他说。我该怎么办？
Do? the girl duck said. How can it go on like this? said the duck. I love a thing that cannot speak, cannot move, cannot-- I don't even know how it feels about me.
做？母鸭子说。这种日子怎么过下去？鸭子说。我爱的东西不会说话，不会动，不能——我甚至不知道它对我有什么感觉。
The girl duck looked at the rock. She didn't know what to say. I know, said the duck, you think I'm crazy. You think it's just a rock. But it isn't just a rock. It's different. It's very different. He looked at the rock. But something has to happen, he said, and soon, because my heart will break if this goes on much longer.
母鸭子看着那块石头。她不知道该说什么。我知道，鸭子说，你以为我疯了。你以为这只是一块石头。但它不仅仅是一块石头。它很特别。它非常特别。他看着那块石头。但必须得发生点什么，他说，而且要快，因为如果这样继续下去，我的心会碎的。
That night, the girl duck had a hard time sleeping. She kept paddling around in circles, thinking about the rock, and the duck, and his heart that might break. She thought long and hard, and before morning, she had an idea. She went and woke up the strange duck.
那天晚上，母鸭子很难入睡。她不停地转着圈游，思考着那块石头，那只鸭子，以及他那颗可能会破碎的心。她深思熟虑了很久，天亮之前，她有了一个主意。她去叫醒了那只奇怪的鸭子。
Things happen when they must, she said, as if it were an extremely meaningful statement. So? said the duck. So I have a plan, said the girl duck. And I think that it will work.
事情发生的时候必须发生，她说，好像这是一个极其有意义的陈述。所以？鸭子说。所以我有一个计划，母鸭子说。而且我觉得它会管用。
Well, what is it? said the duck, nearly bursting with excitement. We will need help, said the girl duck. And it will take some time. And also, we will need a cliff.
嗯，是什么？鸭子说，几乎兴奋得要爆炸。我们需要帮助，母鸭子说。这会花些时间。而且，我们需要一座悬崖。
Two days later they set out. It took four ducks to carry the rock. They worked in teams and traded off every 15 minutes. Everyone joined in, even though they had laughed, for ducks are all brothers when it comes right down to it.
两天后他们出发了。用了四只鸭子才搬动那块石头。他们分组工作，每15分钟轮换一次。每个人都加入了，尽管他们曾嘲笑过，因为当事情真的发生时，鸭子们都是兄弟。
The cliff is over that hill and then quite a ways to the south, said the most elderly duck. I remember flying over it when I was a fledgling. It looked like the edge of the world. The ducks trudged on under their rocky weight for hours. For hours, and then for days. At night they camped under hedges and strange trees, and ate beetles and frogs.
悬崖在那座山后面，然后还要往南走很远，最年长的鸭子说。我记得我还是雏鸟时飞过它。它看起来像世界的尽头。鸭子们顶着沉重的石头重量走了几个小时。几个小时，然后几天。晚上他们宿营在树篱和陌生的树下，吃甲虫和青蛙。
Do you think it will be much farther? said one of the ducks. Maybe, said the old duck. My memory is not so good anymore.
你觉得还要走很远吗？其中一只鸭子说。也许吧，老鸭子说。我的记忆力不如从前了。
On the sixth day, the ducks began to tire. I don't believe there is a cliff, said one of them. Me neither, said another. I think the old duck is crazy. My back hurts, said a third duck. I want to go home. Me too, said a fourth. In fact, I'm going to.
第六天，鸭子们开始疲惫了。我不相信有悬崖，其中一只说。我也一样，另一只说。我觉得那只老鸭子疯了。我的背很疼，第三只鸭子说。我想回家。我也是，第四只说。事实上，我要回去了。
And then all the ducks began to turn for home. The rock fell to the forest floor and lay there. The strange duck looked imploringly at the girl duck. Don't worry, she said. I won't leave you. They watched all the other ducks flee homeward, and then they hoisted the rock onto their backs and trudged on.
然后所有的鸭子都开始掉头回家。石头掉在森林地面上，躺在那里。奇怪的鸭子恳求地看着母鸭子。别担心，她说。我不会离开你。他们看着所有其他鸭子逃回家，然后他们把石头抬到背上继续前进。
What do you think will happen when we throw it off the cliffs? said the duck. I don't know, said the girl duck. I just know it will be something.
你认为当我们把它扔下悬崖时会发生什么？鸭子说。我不知道，母鸭子说。我只知道那会是特别的。
Finally, they came to the edge of the cliff. The drop off was so great they couldn't see the ground. Just great, white clouds spread out before them like an endless, rolling cotton blanket.
终于，他们来到了悬崖边。落差太大了，他们看不到地面。只有巨大的白云在他们面前铺开，就像一张无尽的、翻滚的棉毯。
It looks so soft, said the duck. Yes, it does, said the girl duck. Are you ready? The duck looked at the rock. This is it, my love, he said. The moment of truth. And whatever happens, please remember, always remember, I love you.
它看起来好软，鸭子说。是的，确实，母鸭子说。你准备好了吗？鸭子看着那块石头。就是现在，我的爱人，他说。真相大白的时刻。无论发生什么，请记住，永远记住，我爱你。
And the two ducks hurled the rock off the cliff together. At first, the rock simply fell, like a rock one might say, like a stone. But then something began to happen. It began to slow. It began to grow. It began to change. It narrowed. It elongated. And it also spread sideways.
两只鸭子一起把石头从悬崖上扔了下去。起初，石头只是简单地落下，就像人们所说的那样，像一块石头。但接着发生了变化。它开始变慢。它开始长大。它开始改变。它变窄了。它变长了。它还向两侧展开。
It's becoming a bird, the girl duck said. And it was. It was becoming a beautiful gray bird-- really not that unlike a duck. Its wings began to move slowly up and down, up and down, and it dove down, and then coasted up. It looked back over its shoulder at the two ducks on the cliff, and it called out just once-- goodbye.
它正在变成一只鸟，母鸭子说。确实如此。它变成了一只美丽的灰色大鸟——其实和鸭子没什么两样。它的翅膀开始缓慢地上下移动，上下移动，它向下俯冲，然后顺势滑翔向上。它回头看了一眼悬崖上的两只鸭子，只叫了一声——再见。
And then it was going, going, getting smaller and smaller, flying off over the blanket across the sky. When they reached the pond, the other ducks gathered around and clamored to hear what had happened. The duck and the girl duck glanced at each other. Nothing, said the girl duck. It fell.
然后它就去了，去了，变得越来越小，飞过天空中云层的毯子。当他们回到池塘时，其他鸭子聚拢过来，吵嚷着想知道发生了什么。鸭子和母鸭子对视了一眼。没什么，母鸭子说。它掉下去了。
In the days that followed, the duck stayed to himself. The girl duck went and swam around in circles. She thought about that rocky bird flying off into the sky. She saw it over and over in her mind. And then one day, not too many days later, she looked and saw the duck come swimming up. He was carrying a small salamander in his bill.
随后的几天里，鸭子独自待着。母鸭子游着圈。她想着那只飞向天空的岩石鸟。她在脑海里一遍又一遍地看到那一幕。然后有一天，没过几天，她看见那只鸭子游了过来。他嘴里叼着一只小蝾螈。
For me? the girl duck said. And the duck smiled.
给我的？母鸭子说。鸭子笑了。
Ben Loory, reading a story from his book, Stories for Nighttime and Some For the Day.
本·卢里，阅读他书中的故事，《夜间故事及部分日间故事》（Stories for Nighttime and Some For the Day）。
Act Four, My Girlfriend's Boyfriend. Comedian Mike Birbiglia has this story of some of the extreme things that some of us put up with when we believe that we have found the one person in the world for us. He recorded this in front of a live audience and-- quick warning-- there's not really any sexual, prurient content in the story. But Mike does refer to the fact that sex exists and happens between people.
第四幕，我女朋友的男朋友。喜剧演员迈克·比比利亚讲述了这个故事，关于当我们相信自己找到了世界上那唯一一人时，我们所忍受的一些极端事情。他在现场观众面前录制了这个节目，并且——快速提醒一下——故事里并没有什么露骨的性内容。但迈克确实提到了性是存在的，并且发生在人与人之间。
When I was a senior in high school, I had my first girlfriend, Amanda. And this was a big deal for me, because it was that-- that first time you fall in love, where you're like, oh, there is someone for me. This is it! Like, I found her!
我在高三时有了第一个女朋友，阿曼达。这对我很重要，因为那是——你第一次坠入爱河，你会想，哦，这世上有人属于我。就是她！就像，我找到了！
And she was great. She was so beautiful, and she played tennis, and she wrote for the newspaper, and she was a-- she was a bad girl. And I was a kind of dorky nerd, kind of an outcast. This was at a boarding school that I didn't board at. I was only there because my family lived nearby. And she had major street cred. She had been expelled from her previous school for dealing acid.
她很棒。她很漂亮，打网球，为校报写作，而且她是一个——一个坏女孩。而我是一个书呆子，有点被排斥的人。那是在一所寄宿学校，但我没住校。我只是因为家人住得近才在那儿。她有很高的街头信誉。她因为卖迷幻药而被以前的学校开除了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I remember at one point she said-- it was totally messed up because it was actually this other girl who was dealing acid, and I was framed. And I was like, awesome.
我记得有一次她说——那完全搞砸了，因为实际上是另一个女孩在卖迷幻药，而我被陷害了。我就想，太棒了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I just-- I thought it was one of those things where we were opposites and we knew it, and that made it more exciting. Like, she wanted to be a writer and in student government, and I wanted to know what it was like to be cool.
我只是——我以为那是那种我们性格迥异而我们都知道的情况，这让它更令人兴奋。就像，她想成为一名作家和学生会干部，而我想知道成为酷女孩是什么感觉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, I find that when you fall in love, you tend to overlook certain red flags.
嗯，我发现当你坠入爱河时，你倾向于忽视某些危险信号。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
One of them was that she was a liar.
其中之一就是她是个骗子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I don't mean that in an offensive way. At boarding school, lying is something of a way of life. I remember there was one guy in my class. He was a legendary liar. His name was Keith Robbins. And he used to lick his fingers like a bookie. And he'd go, yeah, yeah. Nice. Nice. Nice.
我不是以冒犯的方式那样说。在寄宿学校，撒谎是一种生活方式。我记得班上有个家伙。他是个传奇的骗子。他叫基思·罗宾斯（Keith Robbins）。他习惯像博彩经纪人那样舔手指。他会说，是啊，是啊。不错。不错。不错。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he would lie about things that weren't important. Like, he'd be like, yeah. Yeah. Nice. My uncle's Tony Robbins, motivational speaker. Yeah. Nice.
他会为无关紧要的事情撒谎。比如，他会说，是啊。是啊。不错。我叔叔是托尼·罗宾斯（Tony Robbins），励志演说家。是啊。不错。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I found out later that that wasn't even true. But even if it were, it wouldn't be that impressive, you know, I--
后来我发现那甚至不是真的。但即使是真的，也没什么好印象深刻的，你知道，我——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So you didn't bother protesting it. You'd just go, oh, OK, Keith. You know? The other red flag was that Amanda used to say really mean stuff to me. And then she'd say, only kidding.
所以你没费心去抗议。你只是会说，哦，好吧，基思。你知道吗？另一个危险信号是阿曼达经常对我说些刻薄的话。然后她会说，开个玩笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She'd be like, you're not good at anything. Only kidding.
她会说，你什么都不擅长。开个玩笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Nobody likes you at all. Only kidding.
根本没人喜欢你。开个玩笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The final red flag was that she told me not to tell anyone she was my girlfriend.
最后的危险信号是她告诉我不要告诉任何人她是我的女朋友。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She had another boyfriend at home that she was in the process of breaking up with. And it was over, but if it got back to him, you know, it'd be bad. So she would go home every weekend and visit him, and at one point she said she had to go home more frequently, because his parents were sick. So she had to console him in that. And I thought, well, you know, the guy's parents are dying. So I ought to be understanding.
她在家里还有另一个男朋友，她正在和那个人分手。虽然已经结束了，但如果让那个人知道了，你知道，那会很糟。所以她每个周末都会回家看望他，有一次她说她必须更频繁地回家，因为他的父母病了。所以她必须以此安慰他。我心想，好吧，你知道，那家伙的父母快不行了。所以我应该体谅。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I also put up with it because I couldn't believe how lucky I was just to be with her. Like, in retrospect, I understand how selfish she was. But at the time, I didn't know that. When you're in a relationship with someone who's selfish, what keeps you in it is the fact that when they shine on you, it's like this souped up shine. And you feel like you're in the club. And you don't even know what the club is. You just you know you want to stay in it.
我也忍受了它，因为我简直不敢相信我有幸能和她在一起。回顾过去，我理解她有多自私。但在当时，我不知道。当你和一个自私的人谈恋爱时，让你留下来的是这样一个事实：当他们关照你时，那就像这种强力加持。你感觉自己进入了俱乐部。你甚至不知道那是什么俱乐部。你只是知道你想待在里面。
We'd been going out two months. And we went on Christmas break and she invited me to meet her parents in New Hampshire. And this is very exciting. This is going to be my big moment. It would vindicate me and legitimize me as the main boyfriend.
我们交往了两个月。圣诞假到了，她邀请我去新罕布什尔州见她的父母。这非常令人兴奋。这是我的重要时刻。这会证明我并使我作为正牌男友的身份合法化。
And so I drive my mom's Volvo station wagon from Massachusetts to New Hampshire. And I meet her parents. And it's going really well. And then this guy shows up.
于是我开着我妈的沃尔沃旅行车从马萨诸塞州到了新罕布什尔州。我见到了她的父母。一切进展得很顺利。然后这个家伙出现了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And his name is Scott. And then the three of us are hanging out. And it dawns on me that I'm hanging out with my girlfriend's boyfriend.
他叫斯科特。然后我们三个在一起玩。我突然意识到我正在和女朋友的男朋友一起玩。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And it's going OK.
一切都还好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He seemed like a good guy. He was an all-state wrestler. And he was remarkably nice. I could totally see what she saw in him.
他看起来是个好家伙。他是一名全州摔跤手。而且非常友善。我完全能明白她在看中他什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And there was some consolation because every time he would go to the bathroom, or go into the other room, she would be very affectionate towards me. She'd kiss my neck, or say something in her sweet voice. But then there was a moment where I was in the bathroom--
而且有一些安慰，因为每当他去洗手间或进入另一个房间时，她就会对我非常亲热。她会吻我的脖子，或者用她甜美的声音说点什么。但后来有一个时刻，我当时在洗手间里——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--and I thought, what's happening in the other room? The day took a strange turn when Scott suggests that we go hang out at his house. And so we go and I meet his parents. It's a very strange thing, meeting your girlfriend's boyfriend's parents for the first time.
——心想，另一个房间里发生了什么？这一天发生了奇怪的转变，当斯科特建议我们去他家玩时。所以我们去了，我见到了他的父母。这是非常奇怪的事情，第一次见到女朋友男朋友的父母。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Part of you is angry, for obvious reasons. And then part of you still wants to make a good impression.
一部分的你很生气，原因显而易见。然后一部分的你仍然想给人留下好印象。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
As a side note, they seemed in perfect health.
顺便说一句，他们看起来身体健康得很。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I drive home, defeated. And I sort of knew that, at this point, this was her life. And I was like her secret life, like on Maury Povich.
我败下阵来，开着车回家。我大概知道，在这一点上，这就是她的生活。我就像她的秘密生活，像《莫里·波维奇》（Maury Povich）节目里那样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I was like, this is it. You know, I'm going to stick up for myself. It's either him or me. And I convinced myself that, given that choice, she would go with me because what we had was so special. So when we got back to school, I called her and I said, we need to talk. Let's meet at the hockey game. And she says, great.
所以我心想，就是这样了。你知道，我要为自己挺身而出。要么是他，要么是我。我告诉自己，做出那个选择后，她会选择我，因为我们拥有的是如此特别。所以当我们回到学校后，我给她打电话说，我们需要谈谈。我们在冰球比赛见面吧。她说，好。
And so I go to the hockey game and she's not there. Hockey game ends, still no sign. I had that pit in my stomach, you know, like this was going to be my moment. And I was going to tell her that she had to pick me or that's it. And so I start walking around the school, to the library, or the cafeteria-- the places she might be.
所以我去了冰球比赛，她没在那。比赛结束了，还是没见人影。我胃里感觉很糟糕，你知道吗，就像这将是我的时刻。我要告诉她她必须选择我，否则就结束了。于是我开始在学校周围走，去图书馆，或者是食堂——她可能在的地方。
And I asked people where she is. And finally, someone says, I saw her with Keith Robbins down at the tennis courts. I remembered earlier that day at lunch, Keith had said to me, I'm sleeping with your girlfriend. You know that, right?
我问别人她在哪里。最后，有人说，我看到她和基思·罗宾斯在网球场那儿。我记得那天午饭时，基思曾对我说，我正在和你女朋友睡觉。你知道吧？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I thought, well, first of all, I hadn't even slept with my girlfriend. So that would be insane. And second of all, he's a liar, so he must be lying. I remember I said to him, yeah. I know. But at this moment it dawns on me that Keith was her new second boyfriend, and I was done. And it was that horrible, lonely feeling where you're walking around some place, and there are people all around, and there's only one person you want to be with, no matter how mean they've been to you.
我心想，首先，我甚至都没和我女朋友睡过。那太疯狂了。其次，他是个骗子，所以他肯定在撒谎。我记得我对他说，是啊。我知道。但就在这一刻，我突然意识到基思是她的新二号男友，而我完了。那是一种可怕的、孤独的感觉，你走在某个地方，周围全是人，但无论她对你有多刻薄，你只想和那一个人在一起。
I just wanted to hear that-- only kidding. I remember people were coming up to me, and I couldn't even hear them. I couldn't even tell them what had happened, because even though I was being dropped, the relationship itself was based on a secret. And that spring, I graduated. Keith was expelled for making fake IDs in his dorm room.
我只想听到那个——开个玩笑。我记得人们走过来找我，我甚至听不到他们在说什么。我甚至无法告诉他们发生了什么，因为尽管我被甩了，但这段关系本身就是基于秘密的。那年春天，我毕业了。基思因为在宿舍做假身份证而被开除了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He had built a life-sized license from Arkansas that people stuck their face in.
他做了一张真人大小的阿肯色州驾照，人们把脸伸进去。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he would photo it, and then laminate it. He later took a job at Goldman Sachs.
他给它拍照，然后塑封。后来他在高盛工作。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That detail seems made up. It's actually true.
那个细节看起来像是编出来的。实际上是真的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And Amanda was expelled the next year for dealing Ritalin. At boarding school, you can't go to the graduation if you're expelled. It's one of the shames of being expelled, and it's very strict. And I found out later that Amanda actually did show up to the graduation, in a disguise. She wore a wig and sunglasses.
阿曼达第二年因为卖利他林被开除了。在寄宿学校，如果你被开除，你就不能参加毕业典礼。这是被开除的耻辱之一，而且非常严格。我后来发现阿曼达竟然乔装打扮出现在毕业典礼上。她戴了假发和墨镜。
My friends laughed about this, the way the friends do, to make you feel better when you've had your heart broken. But I could relate to her doing that because sometimes when you want to be in a place so badly, you'll do anything.
我的朋友们嘲笑这件事，就像朋友们做的那样，想在你心碎时让你感觉好点。但我能理解她那样做，因为有时当你如此渴望待在某个地方，你会不惜一切代价。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Mike Birbiglia, his one-man show, The New One, just finished its run on Broadway. He has a podcast called The Old Ones. It's available whenever you get your podcasts.
迈克·比比利亚，他的个人秀《新的一面》（The New One）刚刚结束在百老汇的演出。他有一个播客叫《老人们》（The Old Ones）。你可以在任何获取播客的地方听到它。
[MUSIC - "WHOLE WILD WORLD" BY WRECKLESS ERIC]
[音乐 - WRECKLESS ERIC的《WHOLE WILD WORLD》]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with help from Elna Baker, Phia Bennin, and Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Cornfield, Sarah Koenig, Jane Marie, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Music help from Damien Graef, Jessica Hopper, and Rob Geddis.
今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）制作，得到了艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）、亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、康菲尔德（Cornfield）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、简·玛丽（Jane Marie）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）的帮助。我们今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。音乐帮助来自达米安·格雷夫（Damien Graef）、杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）和罗布·盖迪斯（Rob Geddis）。
Special thanks today to Justin Collins, Julia McCullough, Amy Silverman, Joshua Kendell, Meg, Jonathan Mitchell, Michael Spivak, Eli Donda, Seth Parrish, Robin Weiss, and Stephanie Brill.
特别感谢今天的贾斯汀·柯林斯（Justin Collins）、朱莉娅·麦卡洛（Julia McCullough）、艾米·西尔弗曼（Amy Silverman）、约书亚·肯德尔（Joshua Kendell）、梅格（Meg）、乔纳森·米切尔（Jonathan Mitchell）、迈克尔·斯皮瓦克（Michael Spivak）、伊莱·唐达（Eli Donda）、塞斯·帕里什（Seth Parrish）、罗宾·韦斯（Robin Weiss）和斯蒂芬妮·布里尔（Stephanie Brill）。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is distributed to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know that show, Cheers? He has this weird theory about the mailman.
我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600期的节目存档。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心 PRX 发行到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道那个节目《欢乐酒店》（Cheers）吗？他有一个关于邮递员的奇怪理论。
I don't believe there is a Cliff.
我不相信世界上只有那么一个（Cliff）。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "WHOLE WILD WORLD" BY WRECKLESS ERIC]
[音乐 - WRECKLESS ERIC的《WHOLE WILD WORLD》]